hello and welcome to the last part of
the forecasting tutorial
my name is tim yanoshovsky i am an
applied science manager at
amazon web services ai labs and i'm
based in berlin
in this last part i'm going to talk a
little bit about forecasting systems
so basically the vehicles that allow us
to bring some of those forecasting
methods
that we've talked about in the previous
parts
to the real world
what i'm going to do is to look at two
extremes
and how to construct forecasting systems
one of them is
we take a simple model
and basically lifted through layers and
layers of
um of processing steps
to a real world problem this is the
mental image of the
of the onion that we have on the left
hand side
this is one extreme and the other
extreme is instead of having a complex
pipeline
we have a complex model and then
relatively simple
processing steps and let me talk about
the onion example first
one thing that you need to do with
classical models in a class
an example for a classical model would
be a state space
state space models or an arima model
is that you you add to the signal that
you have it's
at hand so for example this beer time
series that i'm showing you
here you add a series of pre and post
processing steps
before and after you forecast so in this
example here
is that you first fit a linear trend
toward to de-trend
the time series this is the
result there then next to deseasonalize
and then and then you fit you try to
forecast
the remainder and then of course
you need to then apply those steps again
on top of the signal so you need to
re-seasonalize and retrend the signal
and and this basically means that at the
core we have a simple
simple model and then we have
layers of processing steps around it
each of which can be of
of at least the same complexity as the
original model
the original um forecasting model
and the example i gave you here is a
quite canonical example
often called the stl decomposition but
if you think about more involved
real world examples such as scold starts
yeah we assume in the classical methods
that we always have enough history
available
but this may very well not be the case
so if we have cold starts or no
history available what we typically need
to do is to find some related
or similar items with enough history and
to extrapolate from them
and there those finding similar items
could be an
a very complex model in itself maybe a
clustering step
and the other example would be
promotional lifts so if you have
if you want to forecast the effect of a
promotion
that you've never seen before you
potentially have to have to
independently
estimate the effect of that promotion
before so
you can think about this pipeline really
being arbitrarily complex
consisting of arbitrarily many steps
some pros uh some advantages and
disadvantages of this
approach are is that because we have
rather simple models
at each layer of the onion this is
relatively easy to understand
we're also decomposing we're using the
decomposition principle
so this means that we can decouple quite
well
each model hopefully is quite easily
understandable or somewhat simple
this means that we can inspect it
potentially well we have a white box
approach here
and because many of the classical models
operate on a per time series level
hopefully this is embarrassingly
parallel in a computational sense
however on the flip side
what we what we have here is that we
don't really learn end to end
so this means we have have to invest a
lot of
manual work in modeling
each step here in the pipeline
and this may be maybe hard to tune and
even harder to maintain
because classical models are often local
local methods and or global methods
it's very hard to learn across a
cross-time series
and this can be important in the
scenarios i mentioned earlier
promotional lifts
or or cold starts
and this means that we have to then have
a pipeline of models
cold start i mentioned already and then
because we are in a white box setting
and everything is model based it also
means that we have to model everything
otherwise we won't be able to see those
effects
and you may wonder why why certain why i
didn't mention certain points
that you would typically expect with
with a more classical or non-deep
learning
approaches and i wanted to go through
through some of them
so interpretability is often used as as
an argument in favor of
of more conservatively parameterized
methods however in from a forecasting
system point of view
we are really looking at the
interpretability not of
not of every single layer of the onion
but of the onion itself so while
every model every step or every layer of
the
onion may be interpretable the whole
pipeline might
quite likely not be interpretable
running time may also be the be quite
quite high if we think again about this
cold start use case of promotional lift
so we have to learn across different
times here we're still there
and this means that it may still take a
lot of time
um to run and on-demand forecasting may
be actually harder to realize than one
would think at the beginning
the infrastructure that we have with
this simple models
that may be quite complex because we
have to
we have to combine models in very
sophisticated ways and we have to stage
them appropriately
so this is quite can be quite a system
system challenge to build
and then other things are
maintainability
that is very hard to to train those
systems and to keep evolving those
systems over time
one big concern that you that we have
here is that because we're not learning
end-to-end but we're typically learning
each layer or training each layer
independently
it is not clear that if you improve a
single layer
that you are improving overall overall
performance and it's very hard to say
what is actually an important
bit to get right in the onion
and because we have to we have to stage
different models
in a more sophisticated pipelines it
often means
means that we are much less data
efficient than we would think
because we would always need to reserve
a little bit
for a little bit of data for for
validation and
tuning
in general if you wanted to build a
forecasting system
with classical models we've uh there's a
paper at vldb
2017 on how to do this
um let me just highlight maybe a couple
of things that we've seen
here we've got ensembling as a general
component that we would typically need
with with a smaller with the
with the classical models so that we
make sure that we get not just
not just a single model but we actually
get multiple models
forecasting it and then they have an
overall better improved
accuracy um you would have standard data
cleaning steps at the beginning and
feature transformations of course are as
important
to forecasting accuracy potentially as
their models
one thing that i want to highlight is is
this top layer this analysis layer and
this is one thing where forecasting
systems
may be a little bit different from other
typical machine learning systems in the
sense that
forecasting forecasting systems
they do not have an end-to-end
and do do not face the cus the end
customer consumer
but they're typically consumed by either
systems
other automated systems or business use
users who then
take decisions on them so things like
reporting and plotting is is very is
very important for a business
intelligence
user
now this was one example the other
examples i want to
want to give here is with neural
forecasting
approaches so how do systems
look like um well we've got some
some advantages here that what you would
typically need
is are very very standard feature
engineering
techniques they can that can bring you
um
to they can make sure that
the system is actually fairly well tuned
because
neural networks are typically employed
as global methods
we naturally learn across different time
series
training may take a lot of time but
inference is quite quiet quick
so you can also do it on you can realize
on demand forecasting scenarios quite
well
and what we've seen in the past when
we've
we've looked into productionizing some
of our newer network methods is that
the effect of hyper-perimeter tuning
actually was quite limited
um which if you wanted to turn it around
can be something quite positive um in
the sense that
with default hyper parameter settings
you would get surprisingly
good results and of course an advantage
of
neural forecasting methods is that
they're based on neural networks
and they are currently the state of the
art
in terms of accuracy
so these are advantages some
disadvantages are that
naturally you're giving up control you
have a highly um
or over parametrized method um
what can happen is that you may face
some high variance across different
training runs
so you have to do some tricks like model
averaging there
yes neural networks are still very
costly to train
um and because you have this explicit
training step
maybe in contrast also to classical
classical
methods that are so quick in training
that you can actually do it
do training training and prediction at
the same time
you would need some additional
infrastructure such as model serving
infrastructure
however summarizing it in many
industrial
applications neural networks are the
state of the art
and this has been reflected in in recent
competitions
for example kaggle competitions on
wikipedia
uh web page hit data and the m4
mercury dark is for competition that was
also won by a neural network
and more completely set a neural network
with a with an exponential smoothing
component in it
and the vertex is still out but will
happen in the m5 competition the m5
competition
is currently running on kaggle is
getting quite a lot of traction there
and it's going to be interesting who's
going to win which method is going to
win this and
then of course who also
but overall i think what we can see is
whenever we want to build
a forecasting system it's going to be
complex and this kind of complexity
isn't something that we will not
well really not escape and this is what
i've tried to put here
uh as a conservation law on this slide
so the complexity is either in the
pipeline
all right what you which you would have
in a classical forecasting system
you have a simple model but a complex
pipeline
setup or in a neural forecasting system
where you've got a complex model
but a rather simple pipeline and of
course this is very
you know i'm putting this here for the
for the sake of exposition primarily of
course the truth is somewhere in between
right um maybe you want to also combine
classical methods with
with neural networks um or you want to
be able to override neural networks
in certain sense in certain certain
situations when the
when the forecast potentially go crazy
and also one thing that i i want to
mention here is that neural networks
while i've used them for the for the
sort of other extreme in my in my
explanations they're just one example if
you wanted to use random
random forests because you like them
then you probably would have very very
similar
you come to very similar conclusions
by taking a step back of course
forecasting systems
are just machine learning systems and
there's not nothing too too different
from
forecasting systems than from the
general
machine learning systems so many of the
components
that you would have in a general or what
you would want to have in a general
machine learning system
you would also have have in forecasting
in a forecasting setting with one
difference that i mentioned before is
that
let's say different from recommendations
forecasting is not end consumer facing
but rather is more like a business to
business scenario here
and then in machine learning systems
you've got lots of components that you
will need of course
etl components maybe data provenance
management is important
of course you need some experiment
tracking model ensembling and so on
as a whole laundry list of of of
challenges that we
that you need to solve when you want to
build such a system one thing that i
want to call out is
is a consequence essentially of this b2b
setting of the way
that forecasts are consumed so they are
not consumed by the end consumer
but rather by business users or system
that has that has basically a
consequence in life
testing so yes you would still want to
do live testing with forecasting systems
but because the forecasts are not a
means uh just a means to an end but not
the end in itself
a b tests are often tricky right so
imagine you're you're building forecasts
for an inventory system
then you're not really interested in the
the goodness of your forecast itself
necessarily
right you can you can somewhat see that
quickly or test this quickly in an a b
test also in a live a b test but you're
also interested
in the in whether the buying systems
are making better decisions because
because of your better forecast
hopefully better forecast so these a b
test can have a quite long turnaround
time
and this is an interesting challenge i
think that is
that might be somewhat specific or more
pronounced in forecasting systems
compared to other
general machine learning systems
and then there's some references here on
these
on the components that you might you may
need and build forecast or machine
learning systems
now if you want to get started with
forecasting i think typically you
wouldn't be doing that with
building a forecasting system but rather
trying out some stuff from your laptop
maybe
so i wanted to go over some some tools
some practical tools you have available
to get started here and the first one
the first thing to
to get started with i think our pro is
probably rob heintman's r package
is called forecast
[Music]
there's a new version of it coming out
also but i think the the original
version
is still one of the most
loved and um
and and and robust method out there um
so this is definitely something that you
should look take a look at
but it comes with with a caveat and that
is you have to like
r profit is is something that
is a forecast package um developed by
facebook
that came out in is is a bit more recent
it has uh it has stan as its back end
um it's it's quite flexible but a bit
slow also
is something that you has in our front
end but also a python front end
and then there are other examples uh
tensorflow has
has some um some time series capability
built in and then there's of course a
a plethora of forecasting packages or
time series packages in r
and there's an overview article that we
wrote in 2019
on some of some python based forecasting
open source forecasting packages
now i i mentioned at the beginning that
i'm
part of amazon machine learning
and i want to i want to of course
not spare you from from a bit of a
bit of marketing here so at aws
in particular we have quite a broad and
deep set of capabilities when it comes
to forecasting
so the way aws looks as at its
machine learning offering is in three
different layers we've got the ai layers
ai service layer where you need
relatively
comparatively little data science or
machine learning background
and there's there's an offering there
called amazon forecast i'll go into this
later that basically targets
business or software developers at the
ml services layer this is largely
amazon sagemaker um this is more
targeted
at tech savvier customers we've got deep
ar
as a as a built-in algorithm and then
if you're a scientist or someone who
likes to get his hands really dirty
we've got glue on ts at the ml
frameworks and infrastructure layer
and the way we think about this stack
basically is that you know
the further down you go the more
research orientated you become glue on
ts
and especially is geared towards
towards scientists primarily and the
higher up you go the more business
oriented you are
and let me go over glue on ts first glue
on ts is
as apache license it's out there on
github
it's currently under under review
but there's an archive manuscript
available that we're pointing
to here gluon ts is based on mxnet
in in particular the gluon api for it
and it comes with a plethora of
our forecasting models so dbr is one of
them
we've got we've got deep sp deep state
space models in their deep factor lst
net
a lot of a lot of models are available
mq mq cnn for example
and what is quite nice is that if you
want ever have a new modeling idea
you will be able to come up with with a
new model hopefully more quickly
than if you started from scratch
and here's some some components that we
have in glue on ts
we yeah we have some some
some components that basically take care
of some heavy lifting
like object serial serialization and
hyper parameter validation that
that you will need to solve at some
stage um
when you're writing a more or when
you're going to spend more time
on on a machine learning problem and it
also comes
with a lot of time series time series
utility methods
we have some data sets that we can that
you can access quite easily with
with glue on ts there's a bunch of
public data sets available for which we
have loading
loading capabilities built in including
the m5 competition
and and then there are feature
transformation steps that you can do
that
that are quite flexible and they're all
part of this transform
transform package
and then in the model and the model and
i'll go into this a little bit deeper
is is the way we're going to the way we
define
our our forecasting models with the
standard sort of
estimator predictor interface it's very
similar to let's say what spark
and and scikit-learn do
and then back testing is something that
is maybe a bit particular to forecast
and we talked about this earlier
um where this is important also to get
right so
in forecasting experimentation so
there's
there's quite quite some tooling there
that helps you
helps you in making this a bit easier
and then here's some examples that we
have available in glue on ts
so we've got lots of metrics for
computation metrics of course are
something that you want to get right
and you don't want to have a bug there
so having a well-tested
suite of of forecasting metrics out
there
is important and sometimes for example
in the continuous
ranked probability score they may not be
as easy to implement so
it might be nice that something is
already there we've got lots of
distributions
for modeling the output
things like negative binomial
distribution or if you want to go
slightly known pyramid require splines
[Music]
and that's also possible and then we've
got all kinds of
times through specific transformations
such as the venerable box cox
transformations that you can also deeply
embed into your models
now here's an example of how easy it is
to
to to set up a
forecasting model or to run a
forecasting experiment
with gluon ts so after a couple of
standard imports
you can get quite get quite easily get a
data set
here in this case it's the electricity
consumption then you define in
in this case an estimator the deep ar
estimator
with some some hyper parameters
you train it this estimator and then
evaluate define some evaluation metrics
quantize that are going to be in
interesting to you in this case we chose
0.1 0.5 0.9
you know but you could choose something
else here and then we evaluate this in
in backtest
blue on ts uses matlab lip for for
plotting
plotting or forecast of course metrics
are great but they can only
sort of tell you a little uh one part of
the story
looking at forecast is going to be a
very important step
as as is for any machine learning
problem
and we and what we have what we have
here is that we can
we have some utility functions that
allow you to plot
forecasts a little bit a little bit
nicer or a little bit more easily
so in this case here we show we showed
different quantiles 0.1 and 0.9
and the way we assemble models and i
want to talk about this for a moment
is basically by by
combining it from different components
so if you think about dbar
by dbis in neural network and rnn or
lstm
consists of that of that component it
essentially is
a stepwise rolling forward uh model so
it's a canonical model
and as an output distribution you know
it uses
parameterized distributions such as
student t negative binomial or gaussian
on the other hand if you take let's say
a deep state space model
you know the the distribution there
currently is a gaussian
distribution there's an update going to
be coming out hopefully soon
where we can have normalizing flows also
it has gone to deep state space mo deep
state space
models rely on state space models
as the probabilistic component again
it's a
it's not a sequence to sequence setup
but a canonical setup
and we're going to estimate the state
space model parameters with an lstm
so this is a good way to see how how the
different systems are
are playing together here the different
components are playing together here
you want the s we launched it in summer
last year it's almost one year in
we're quite happy with the with the
community traction we've seen so far
so there's a couple of of of additional
forecasting uh models
that came in through through community
efforts something like lstnet
or or n beats
they are they are part of of glue on ts
now
we will have more time series
applications coming in
blue on ts is it's not called glue and
forecast but glue on time series for a
reason so we want to have we want to
broaden the horizon
a bit more and go into other
applications that need time series
analysis
we will have more more model and more
other components coming in i mentioned
normalizing flows as a as an example
that is hopefully going to come in soon
and then there's some some some general
work that we need to do on and hopefully
that the community helps us also to do
um to make umts more flexible for back
testing of course
documentation could always be better
okay this was basically the the
ml frameworks layer on the
on the the next layer upwards from
of the aws offerings what we have is is
steep ar
um that's a it's an algorithm that was
available in glue on ts open source but
also
in sagemaker in a slightly different
version
and and because it's available in
sagemaker you can take advantage of all
the
of all the tooling that comes comes in
sagemaker so you can quickly
build train and deploy machine learning
models and because it's fully managed
bringing this dbr-based solution to
production should be relatively
straightforward
and finally on the on the highest level
layer of the aws
machine learning stack we've got amazon
forecast
which allows you to to really quickly
generate a
forecast solution with a couple of
clicks
here here we take a deep learning model
in five clicks and then you've got a
production solution up and running
so you only essentially have to set up a
data pipeline
if you want to you choose you use auto
machine learning
or one or you can also directly choose
one of the one of the algorithms
available in forecast for example an
enhanced version of deep ar
if you've ensured that the accuracy is
actually
with what you're expecting you can then
in the fourth
step deploy the predictor and then you
set up
in production and you can generate
forecasts
yeah so so amazon forecast really is is
forecasting as a service allows you to
to quite
to set up forecasting forecasting
pipeline quite rapidly but then also to
work with it
and to continue to customize it
as you as you dive deeper into your
problem
so we've seen this slide before it's
it's it's the summary of the
the aws offering at the at the ml
frameworks layer we have new on ts
then dbai and sagemaker and then finally
for business oriented users amazon
forecast at the top layer
and with this we've come to the end of
this tutorial
i want to thank you for your attention
and want to point you to the the website
that we set up for this
where you see all material all the
slides and
additional material on the website and
in particular we've
you will see the references
that um that are coming on the slides
here that i will not record
but you can you can get them from the
website
and with this i hope you've enjoyed the
tutorial
goodbye
you